who doesn't remember the Mighty Ducks
the team of scrubs that nobody thought
had a chance but with the use of a
certain coach who doesn't think you'll
fit in but then finds the strength to
stand by his team they will go to the
finals and oh come on even before this
story was used over and over and over
again it was already tired which is a
shame because there's nothing in Mighty
Ducks that's especially bad but there's
nothing that's especially good in it
either Emilio Estevez plays a rich man
who gets in trouble so he's been
sentenced to having to coach a little
league hockey team and of course they're
all troublemakers and goofy and wacky
and at first his plan is to win game
simply by having them call fouls yeah
anytime they're tapped he wants him to
fall down and fake these injuries that's
actually pretty funny but one kid simply
won't do it and says that he wants to
fight because he loves the sport and he
loves what he does
Estevez thinks maybe he should start
doing the same thing and tries to
encourage the kids to be stronger and of
course through determination hard work
they all come together and yeah
sometimes they fall off the wagon but
they get right back on because they love
their coach and they love their team and
they make it to the big playoffs and all
that good stuff what can I say about
this movie that hasn't been said about
every single movie that has this plot I
guess it kind of did it early on but
didn't we have Bad News Bears and a few
other films before it I think people saw
it because the cast of kids they have
were actually pretty good and pretty
entertaining but they weren't written
that way they were more acted that way
they had the silly faces they had the
goofy performances and yeah kids are
gonna like that and for a lot of younger
people this is the first time they're
seeing this story and like I said before
there's nothing really bad in it I mean
it feels at the time fine there's some
atmospheric moments I do like it when
Estevez goes to see his old coach but
you just gotta like this formula in this
setup if you're gonna like this film and
I don't I thought was tired and boring
the first time I saw it and I think it's
tired and
even the sequel's which I'm not going to
review by the way because if you like
reviewing the same movie over and over
are pretty much the same except insert
laziness with something else like in the
second one it was Fame they let fame go
to their head and now they have to get
back in training and then the third one
come robbery and teamwork starts to fall
apart and it's just not worth it
looking back out years later I just find
it as a huge bore really tell me at the
beginning this movie you don't know
scene for scene what's gonna happen and
is there really anything that hilarious
to keep you connected to it I remember
why I saw it as a kid I liked it but
once and I didn't really get why
everybody had to buy this movie and have
it in their collection and nowadays our
generation knows this story about the
sports team that has to be built up and
will somehow succeed as the mightyduck
story but even before Mighty Ducks this
story was around and even before it
existed it was still kind of boring if
you like it great but I never got into
these stories and I don't think I ever
will I know a lot of people like it but
personally I couldn't give a punk
you